this morning some border checkpoints
around Russia are filled with young men
trying to leave the country The Exodus
follows the Russian government's move to
call up some 300 000 Reserve troops to
join the war on Ukraine President Putin
is seeking to regain momentum in a war
that is now in its seventh month after
some stunning setbacks on the
battlefield the rapada is in Ukraine
where Russian troops fled from the
Ukrainian Army's recent advance
call up of military reservist has not
gone down well at home with hundreds
trying to get out of the country to
avoid being drafted but many citizens
received their papers within hours of
Putin's announcement effective
immediately
holding on tightly
no time for speeches only Hasty goodbyes
and tearful farewells as Citizens called
up to fight and Vladimir Putin's War
head off to training camps for loved
ones left behind the cold grip of Fear
Putin's men have not been faring well on
Ukraine's battlefields Russia estimates
they've lost nearly 6 000 Soldiers the
U.S puts those killed or wounded at
around 80 000.
flight side of the country are booked
solid a panicked Exodus of Russians
trying to escape conscription I feel
that not really many lots of Russians
people want to to fight and want to be
immobilized and want to go to them and
at border exits to Georgia Finland and
Serbia traffic has been backed up
in the Far East of Russia another long
line new conscripts unable to dodge this
bullet boarding military planes many of
these Reserve soldiers have never fought
in a war let alone one that already has
even hardened Russian fighters on the
back foot
Ukrainian soldiers may be outgunned and
outmanned but Special Forces senior
Lieutenant taras perezowitz told us his
men are more Nimble with a vital weapon
on their side technology one of the
stars of this war has been satellite
devices used by Ukrainian troops on the
front lines to communicate anywhere
anytime swiftly to avoid detection it's
Modern Warfare It's Modern Warfare
absolutely never seen before I think one
of the reasons why Russians lost because
they completely been outdated
but this is a long way going far from
over today and occupied territories
Russia has begun referendums to push
through a vote allowing Putin to Annex
those regions just like he did in Prime
near Gale
Deborah patter reporting from Ukraine we
thank you